we are going to make boy band history
tonight it is so fantastic
amazing fantas
[Music]
awesome okay either she just made that
up or I have not been paying attention
we're going to have the best family
reunion ever hold on your cupcakes 1 2
makes me feel
so I do my ha to St my nails baby how
you feeling feel good as
hell get up
everybody you got the right
[Music]
[Applause]
stuff looks like your Band-Aid aren't
behind
you getting the band start together this
is our most fun mission yet yay
milkshakes to
celebrate got to flex the drip we've
gone from Boys to Men and now there's
only one direction for us to
go the back
streets trolls band together just let me
take you to a better
place I'm going to make it
the me dles sneak previews November 4th
in theaters everywhere no mber 17th get
tickets now